TIM ANDERSON: Welcome to
Tech Tips From Teachers.
On this episode, we'll be
looking at student tool apps.
Our guest today
is Kyle Brumbaugh,
from San Jose, California.
Kyle's been in
education for 25 years,
and is currently the Director
of Educational Innovation
and Information Services at
a large Bay Area high school.
He also recently co-authored a
book on classroom technology.
Kyle, thanks for joining us.
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: Thank you for
having me here at Google, Tim.
TIM ANDERSON: How are
you seeing technology
affecting learning for students
and teachers in the classroom
today?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH:
Well, it just really
has expanded over
the last few years.
Technology and the
number of technologies
that are available for
students and teachers
has just exploded, really, in
the last three to four years,
even.
Teachers now have access,
and students have access,
to a variety of
resources that they never
had access to before.
Really, the libraries of the
world and all the information
in the world is accessible
to them at their fingertips,
right at their desks.
TIM ANDERSON: Very cool.
And if we're
thinking specifically
about those student actions
like studying and note taking,
how is technology
playing a part in those?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: Well,
there's so many apps
right now that
really allow students
to leverage their
study, or to make
their study more effective.
Some of the apps with
flash cards or ways
to quiz themselves,
or teachers to provide
quizzes as formative assessments
so that the teachers can gauge
where the students are at.
And the students
can gauge themselves
where they're at, so
they know, really,
how to focus their study on
what the things they need
to learn for that next task
that they may take in class.
TIM ANDERSON: For student
tool applications,
it's important that developers
prioritize a few key things.
It's crucial that these apps can
be used anytime and anywhere,
and it's important that
they're highly customizable,
and allow students to
collaborate with one another,
as well.
TIM ANDERSON: Why
is it so important
that these apps can be used in
a variety of places, variety
of circumstances,
variety of times?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: Well, you
want to extend the learning
outside the classroom.
One of the benefits of having
students with technologies
is that they can now use those
technologies anytime, anyplace.
So I start to think of now that
student who was maybe learning
something in a
biology class, now
has the opportunity to, on
their way home on the bus,
open their phone and go
through a series of flash cards
that now will deepen
their learning from what
they learned in class.
Also, at a high
school level, one
of the big things that
happens to a lot of students
is they miss some class
because of athletic events,
or some other
extracurricular activities.
Now, while they're
on the way traveling
to some of these
extracurricular activities,
they can actually study what
they've been learning in class
or what they missed in class,
because the teacher can provide
that content to them in a
digital format that really
wasn't accessible just
a few years before.
TIM ANDERSON: Definitely.
And then what about that
customization piece?
Why is that something that's
so important for these sorts
of tools?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: Well,
the customization piece
is really important because it
actually targets the learning.
It takes the student,
and really allows
the student to
assess themselves,
or the teacher to assess
what the student knows.
And so the teacher
and/or the student
can target what they really
don't understand, and spend
the time learning those
skills, and then bringing them
into the whole so they really
have an entire picture of what
the learning goals are, and what
the learning outcome should be.
TIM ANDERSON: Very cool.
And then on that
collaboration piece,
I feel like that's
something that
is sort of a buzzword
these days in education.
Why is that something
that's so important
to integrate into apps?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH:
Well, collaboration
is huge, because
you want to allow
students to work together.
Because that's what they're
going to do in the work world.
When they leave
school, they need
to be able to collaborate
with their peers.
They need to be able to
work as part of a team.
These apps allow students
to work as part of a team,
and because of that, they learn
some socialization skills,
they learn how to
divvy up the work,
or how to separate out the work.
But then bring it
back to a whole
so that everybody has the
same level of understanding.
Teachers can manage that process
by assigning different roles
to different students.
But, at the same
time, or at the end
when they have a
culminating project,
the teacher can now assess
the group as a whole,
and really be able
to parse out--
which was one of
the negative things
with collaborative
learning in the past--
was that teachers
really couldn't suss out
which student had done what.
Now, because of the way
the tools are structured,
teachers can really kind of
look at what students have
done as part of the collective.
And then what students
know individually,
and not just what the
group project presents out
to the entire class.
TIM ANDERSON: Let's take a
look at some exemplar student
tool applications.
Kyle, first up.
Quizlet-- why is that such
a strong student tool?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH:
Well, Quizlet really
gives students and
teachers the opportunity
to create that anytime,
anyplace learning.
So a student could start
off in the classroom using
Quizlet on a tablet,
and then transition
from using that tablet to
their phone out on the quad,
on the way home.
Virtually any place they want to
use that application they can.
Teachers can actually set
up some listening skills,
and some vocabulary just
using the auditory components
of Quizlet.
Also, Quizlet allows teachers
to create quizzes using images,
so that it can be more of a
sight-recognition type of tool.
So there's plenty
of different things
that they can do in Quizlet.
TIM ANDERSON: And
what about Papyrus?
What makes that such a
great app for the classroom?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: So one of
the things with Papyrus
is that it's really
customizable, in that you
can go through, and you
can change the colors,
you can change the pressure,
you can change the thickness.
It really is responsive to
the touch of the student
using the application.
Which is unique.
The other things that
you can do with Papyrus
is that you can bring in
content from other places.
For example, you could
actually take a picture
with your phone or your
tablet, bring it into Papyrus,
and mark it up or annotate it.
TIM ANDERSON: And
then what about
with StudyBlue, what makes
it such a valuable tool
for students?
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: So
first of all, StudyBlue
has a wealth of information.
They have over 250,000 decks
that users or teachers can
pull from, to really
say, I want my students
to learn about this.
But the other piece
with StudyBlue
that really makes it effective
is that ability for students
to collaborate-- to create
decks collaboratively,
and that they can now share
those decks back and forth
with each other, and then
share those, actually,
back with the teacher.
So the teacher can really
say, if these students really
think these are the
most important things,
I really need to make sure that
I hit those things in class.
TIM ANDERSON: So
there you have it.
For student tool
applications it's
important that they can be
used anywhere and anytime,
that they're highly
customizable,
and that they allow for
collaboration among students.
For more episodes, check out
the Google Developers YouTube
channel.
Kyle, thanks for joining us.
KYLE BRUMBAUGH: Thank
you for having me, Tim.
TIM ANDERSON: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]